We all know we're unique individuals but
the important question is, are you normal?
For example if you're right-handed,
then yes you're in the norm.
85% of the global population is as well
and even if both of your parents
are left-handed there's only a 25%
chance that you will be too but,
if you can't roll your tongue you're not normal.
65% to 81% of the population can.
Have dark hair? Normal and only 0.5% of people have red hair.
Had your wisdom teeth removed?
Around 65% of people worldwide need this done.
And if you wear glasses, you
may be part of the growing norm
affecting around 2.5 billion people worldwide.
It's believed that increased
indoor activity in childhood plays a
major role in the risk of being nearsighted.
If you're single in the U.S you're normal as well.
"Phew", 50.2% of adults in America are single
which is a big shift from 1970
when only 37.4% were unwed.
Worldwide however, 80% of adults have married.
Regardless of marital status the
average age to have a baby in the U.S
is 22.8 for women and 25.4 for men
where as somewhere like Chad the average is 17.9
while Greece is 31.2 years old.
And if you just had a baby and its name is
Sophia or a variant of that,
so did most other normal parents given that it's the
top baby name in nine countries.
If you're having safe and protected sex you're normal too.
65.8% of men between 15 to 44 report
using a condom the first time they had sex,
compared to 2006 where only 47.7% used one.
This trend is even more prevalent among
teens between 15 to 19 years old with
78.1% using condoms their first time.
But what age is normal to lose your virginity?
When sexual intercourse is
defined as penile to vaginal sex, the CDC
found an average age for American women
to be 17.2 years old and 16.8 for men.
Have a job?
61.3% of people are employed with
the most common or normal occupation in
America being; retail jobs followed by,
cashier's, office clerks, food prep, and
serving, registered nurses, and wait staff.
But if you're serving somebody who
enjoys dairy past childhood, they aren't normal.
Approximately 75% of
adults in the world have some form of
lactose intolerance, meaning they
experience unpleasant digestive symptoms
from dairy products.
And if they're a vegetarian, they're in the minority too,
with only 4-5% in North America
and a little over 30%
in India excluding meat from their diet.
Have a birthday in February? Weirdo!
Most people are born around August and September.
Statisticians theorize that as
the temperature drops, people spend less
time outside, causing things to heat up
in the bedroom and nine months later,
lots of babies are born and these babies
are feeding from an average bra size in
America of 36C, an increase from the
34B, fifteen years ago.
And the average erect penis size?
13 centimeters or 5 inches.
Which is smaller than initial studies found
but, most of those relied on self-reporting
as opposed to actual studied measurements.
If you're not exactly feeling normal now.
Don't worry!
We have a whole video on why humans are weird as well.
Like why does water leak
from our eyes when we're sad?
Or why do we bang our hands together to show approval?
Click on the screen or the link
in the description for that video and
subscribe for more weekly science videos
every Thursday.